do you remember when I smoked a
cigarette and you got really mad at me
we've been together for three years now
I would say every story I ever tell
really she likes to butt in and say like
to my defense you embellish a lot when
you tell stories I remember details
really well I'm gonna tell a story about
when Brianna first met my parents
it'll be actually the first time she met
my dad I believe she had met my mom
previously I really wasn't worried about
her mom I can't remember if I met her
before so it was really a big deal
because this is my first relationship
with a woman and my dad I had actually
kind of recently come out to him so it
was a really big deal for me it's a
introduce her to my dad I was terrified
because I know her coming out to her
parents was pretty hard and just because
of that I kind of initially thought that
they wouldn't be really accepting and I
was kind of scared that he wouldn't like
me so they came and visited us my dad
was really friendly and he talked to her
and they got along as I thought they
would and it was amazing because he
actually went out of his way and I knew
who's out of his comfort zone cuz the
whole thing was so new to him
her dad always kind of you know like a
stern guy I think we shook hands and he
ended up asking me about my eBay stuff
which actually turned out to be like a
bonding moment because I was just going
to school full-time
so I was really broke and so I would
sell my stuff on eBay he didn't act like
it was weird at different or anything
and they talked about eBay because they
both love selling stuff on eBay we
talked about eBay for a bit and he's
like oh I just sold a fifty thousand
dollar tractor on eBay and it's like
cool I just made five bucks we ended up
getting along we ended up going to
brunch and we brought our roommate for
some reason who I've been friends with
since high school my dad has known him
for a while so my dad was like oh hey
Chad you can come with us to to brunch
and I was like really dad okay
so it's me not his dad Nadia's mom and
her roommate I mean he was a pretty good
time it was still like really weird I
didn't know kind of like where I stood
my dad actually spend a lot of time
talking to Chad too
she has just like a super likable guy
Nadia's dad just loved him to the point
where they were like cheering at brunch
and I don't know why he did that it's a
bad thing like should I beginning Cheers
like what's going on here so after we
had brunch we went back to the apartment
we were gonna go for a walk I remember
and I was smoking a cigarette real quick
and they came out and I ended up like
you know putting it out just just in
case Nadia just like started like kind
of yelling at me she's like kidding me
they hate and it was me and my mom
walking and Rihanna and my dad walking
and we were all kind of like having a
conversation separate and it was just it
was really cute and I was talking mostly
with her mom I've got this really bad
habit of not listening to people when
they're talking and so I just remember
she was telling a story and I definitely
started zoning out looking around
there's a lot of stuff going on outside
she kind of ended her story and I was
just kind of like uh-huh okay overall it
went so well and I'm just really
grateful for like how cool my dad was
about the whole thing because again the
whole thing was very new for him
[Music]
I hope you recalled it in a positive
happy sweet way do you remember when I
smoked a cigarette and you got really
mad at me yeah you weren't supposed to
do that my mom smelled it right away and
my dad thinks it's disgusting and I was
like could have just waited they were
gonna leave in like an hour we went for
a walk yeah I just remember it being
such a sunny day and it's nice and
watching you continue to like bond with
my dad I don't remember me talking to
your dad I remember talking to your mom
and ignoring her family that's perfect
oh the thing that my brain does I was
and you were talking to my dad I only
remember talking to your mom that's so
weird
I don't remember talking to him I
definitely feel embarrassed for bragging
about how well I remember details and
memories and situations shot myself in
the foot there no there's a good time
I'm really glad it happened and I'm
really glad they liked you yeah now we
all get along really well
[Music]